one of my patients said to me I'm not
afraid of dying he said I'm more afraid
of living
[Music]
again I'm not an advocate for the
massive and I think tremendously
overdone use of medications but I can
tell you that the first time I took
antidepressant after a few days I said
you mean people can feel like this
normally a lot of life to come to you
you don't have to force it and open your
heart don't just focus on your
clever brain so much
and open your heart and see what
possibilities reveal themselves to you
and that
it's not your fault
the way the world is and even the way
you are it's not your fault it's not a
fault
just
accept yourself
I'll tell you two things I
when is that an aunt who is a physician
herself
and she had not wanted to be a doctor
she wanted to be a writer but complying
with her father's wishes she went to
medical school
and she was taken to usherits where you
saw she saw her parents taken in one
direction to the gas Chambers and she
was sent in another
and
very sensitive very wounded soul but she
saw me much more clearly when I was
younger than I could see myself
and once you quoted Shakespeare to me
and I know it's a cliche and I know that
it's in the mouth of the character
Polonius in whom Shakespeare puts this
phrase it's even hypocrisy
but it's so true she wrote to me to dine
on selfie too I wish I'd understood what
that meant but that's the best advice I
got
and then when I was a physician
but the part of me that I wanted to
write
had really expressed themselves
that was really in me to write and to
share something with the world
and I had a patient who used to be an
English professor at University of
British Columbia it was quite a
well-known Canadian poor Warren town
he said to him when he came to the
office once for a medical visit I said I
want to write but I don't know why
he said don't worry about it you were
right when you're starting to teach the
world
and that's what happened
experience also stressed and sensitive
kids pick up on that stress they don't
know what to do with it they tuna
there's their small children when their
brains are developing it's not a genetic
disease it's an Adaptive response the
problem with adaptive responses is they
help you at the time but later on they
become problems
and it was adaptive at one point
maladaptive at another Point again the
problem is that they're not conscious
adaptations they have to believe in your
own truth and you have to deepen your
relationship to your truth
and you'll connect with people that
are also seeing the same truth as you
are even if they don't see the way you
do
so never be afraid of your own truth
and to explore it also don't be afraid
to let go of it if you find that there's
a deeper truth that
that speaks to you and at the same time
whatever you do out there in the world
do an equal amount of work internally
because if you don't you work in the
world well not be as effective
if the success of a doctor is to be
measured by how long his patients live
then I'm a failure because my patients
die very young relatively speaking they
die of HIV they die of hepatitis C they
die of infections of their heart valves
they've dive infections of their brains
of their spine of their hearts of their
bloodstream they die of suicide of
overdose of violence of accidental
deaths
and if you look at them
you you call to mind the words of the
great Egyptian novelist now give them a
Foos who wrote nothing records the
effects of a sad life as graphically as
the human body because these people lose
everything they lose their health they
lose their beauty they lose their wealth
they lose human relationship and in the
end they often lose their lives and yet
nothing shakes them from their addiction
nothing can force them to give up their
addiction the addictions are powerful
and the question we have to ask is why
are people afraid of life
and
if you want to understand addiction you
can't look at what's wrong with the
addiction you have to look at what's
right about it in other words what is
the person getting from the addiction
what are they getting that otherwise
they don't have and what addicts get are
relief from us from Pain what they get
is the sense of Peace a sense of control
a sense of calmness very very
temporarily and the question is why are
these qualities missing from their lives
what happened to them
if you look at the drugs like heroin
like morphine like codeine if you look
at cocaine if you look at alcohol these
are all painkillers
one way or another they all soothe pain
and that's what the real question and
addiction is not why the addiction but
why the pain
if my value depends on how much I'm
helping others it becomes addictive and
the reason becomes addictive is because
there's always a negling doubt inside
which is maybe unconscious but says okay
they want me but do they want me or do
they want what I'm giving them so that
that satisfaction of getting that praise
and valuation from the outside is a
temporary hit like somebody's temporary
hit from heroin yeah and then you have
to have it again and again and again our
culture rewards that kind of addiction
Big Time values it and and and and
esteems it meanwhile the soul is being
grown to dust inside I ask people well
if you've been to a Cardiologist or a
respirologist or oncologist or a
dermatologist a neurologist any kind of
an ologist in the last five years just
raise your hands it's a lot you know out
of a 500 people in a room
half of them at least will put their
hands up sure maybe more and then I'll
say now keep your hands up if they asked
you about any childhood trauma your
current relationship any stresses at
work how do you feel about yourself as a
human being the hands mostly go down
yeah and yet yet I'd say to people and I
say this with full scientific backing
that those questions that are not being
asked are what drove you to that doctor
in the first place whether that trauma
manifested in chronic physical illness
or or mental health conditions or
addictions that's the source and unless
you deal with that Source you're only
dealing with symptomatology and not
actual cause all trauma is stressful but
not every stress is traumatic the
sentence people use the word to refer to
difficult experiences which is not the
same as being traumatized and on the
other hand where it really matters which
is in the area of Health that you and I
are both concerned in whether it's
physical or mental health trauma is not
understood nearly enough or used nearly
enough so that in my mind a lot of
conditions of mind and body are actually
very much trauma related without the
healing profession particularly their
medical profession actually recognizing
it so tramadan is it comes from the
Greek word for wounding drum is a wound
it's a psychicond that leaves a scar it
leaves an imprint in your nervous system
in your body in your psyche and then
shows up in multiple ways that are not
helpful to you later on so and it's in
its basic sense trauma is a psychic
wound and if you look at the nature of a
wound
um on the one hand if it's raw and open
it really hurts so when somebody touches
their wound that you sustained a long
time ago
but that hasn't healed yet you will
react like you're just being tormented
all over again this happens in
relationships all the time on the other
end
uh wounds scar over and the scar tissue
has certain features is very hard it's
rigid so it's not flexible so people
tend to be rigid when they traumatized
it also doesn't grow so drama very often
stops emotional growth and development
so no one else is very raw and painful
on the other hand it's even lacks
sensation because Scar Tissue doesn't
have nerve endings in it
but Ramadan just to finish is not what
happened to you so trauma is not
difficult incidence electron is not the
war it's not the in my case the second
world war when I was born or what
happened to me Brahma is not the abuse
that people experience drama is not the
pain that they felt drama is the
Moon that is sustained as a result
he promised the wound that we sustained
it can be healed at any time it'll never
not have happened but if the wound is
what happened to people inside as a
result
that can be healed